[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono qui a come rappresentante del
collettivo moleste queste che vi leggerò
sono le parole che abbiamo scelto
una volta venne contattata per un
progetto in cui oltre al portfolio era
richiesta la presentazione delle mie
notti che
mi avevano presentato questo autore per
cui avevo una vera ammirazione con
sorpresa mi contattò tramite social ma
in modo viscido e subdolo diventò sempre
più opprimente
ho cercato di non inimicarmi lo perché
non volevo avere delle ripercussioni
lavorative
durante una fiera mi ero ritrovato a
cena con un autore famoso che non
conoscevo di persona
mentre gli altri erano lontani a fumare
mi spinse contro un portone bloccandomi
le spalle e iniziò a dirmi porcate
io ho detto no
inventando una scusa da quel momento il
mio lavoro non gli piaceva più ha smesso
di scrivermi in privato ma anche di
rispondere alla mia e mail didattiche ha
iniziato a umiliarmi davanti agli altri
allievi
in seguito ho saputo che i miei voti
erano stati bruscamente abbassati
addirittura mi voleva bocciare
mi ha dato uno schiaffo ed era colpa mia
che me l'ero cercata mi ha messo le mani
al collo ma era colpa mia che ho
ingigantito la cosa mi ha tradita
confessandomi dettagli in stile
almodo'var mi ha trasmesso una malattia
ma era colpa mia che somatizza va poi
una volta abbiamo anche collaborato per
la realizzazione di un evento
alla fine lui è uscito sul palco a
prendersi gli applausi e a ringraziare
tutti il mio nome ha dimenticato di
farlo era mio marito
nell'estate del 2020 in america è
scoppiato un caso mediatico legato al
mondo del fumetto superomistico un
autore famoso autorevole affermato
warren ellis è stato accusato da
multiple fonti di molestie sessuali in
ambito lavorativo per intenderci sulla
portata delle 20
diciamo un po warren ellis come bill
cosby per il mondo delle sit com
una volta scoperchiata la pentola
americana il problema viene preso in
considerazione anche in italia
l'innesco è stato un articolo di
francesca torre su un sito specializzato
i giorni seguenti la redazione ha
ricevuto una piangere e mail messaggi
commenti testimonianze aprendo una
discussione e mettendo in contatto tra
loro professioniste processo iniziera il
settore che hanno cominciato a
confrontarsi tra loro e dal confronto
sono diventate e chiare scomode verità
che fino a quel momento erano sussurrati
a mezza voce
non solo l'unione fa la forza
l'unione fa l'azione nell'ottobre del
2020 nasce ufficialmente moleste
il primo collettivo transfer minista
all'interno del mondo del fumetto in
italia
gli obiettivi li moleste sono stati da
subito molto concreti come creare un
luogo di ascolto per chi ha subito
episodi molestie di natura la sessista
omo trans fobica o intessere una rete di
sostegno con i centri antiviolenza
disseminati in tutta italia per
indirizzare chi ha bisogno di assistenza
verso specialisti del trauma in legge ma
non vogliamo solo trovare un modo di
raccogliere i cocci di riparare il danno
lo vedremo prevenire
scritti così nero su bianco gli
obiettivi ci sembravano semplici e oggi
neanche noi sapevamo esattamente con
cosa ci stavamo confrontando ma eravamo
tutte tristemente coscienti e ripeto
tristemente coscienti che un settore
così tanto informale come quello del
fumetto che storicamente ha avuto spazi
molto angusti per le donne basato su
un'infinità di gerarchie di aspirazioni
personali
ammirazioni invidie senza albo
professionale con pochissime garanzie
sindacali
beh in questo settore il terreno degli
abusi è particolarmente fertile
il primo passo di moleste era rendere
chiaro a tutti quanto quanto questo
terreno forse inquinato il portare in
superficie è quello che tutti già
sapevano
una volta aperto il vaso di pandora non
si sarebbe più potuto fare finta di
nulla
intendiamoci
non tutto il settore del fumetto è
popolato di persone abusanti o da
molestatori però bastano pochi soggetti
e basta soprattutto l'omertà che li
circonda
per rendere un ambiente un posto non
sicuro sotto troppi punti rivista
possono essere avanzano richieste di
insegnanti i responsabili di progetti
autori con maggior potere oppure ricatti
che mirano a ottenere attenzioni
sessuali in cambio di opportunità
lavorative
relazioni amicali
abusanti dove il rifiuto di favori
sessuali diventa mobbing ed esclusione
dal mercato del lavoro il grooming
l'adescamento online come è pratica
diffusa e accettata
i casi di molestie durante le fiere
durante i colloqui di lavoro ma anche la
discriminazione su base estetica e
soprattutto la difficoltà a trovare
sostegno proprio nel proprio ambiente
lavorativo quando si verificano abusi
violenze qui non si tratta solo di
rompere il tetto di cristallo e
permettere un accesso equo ai ruoli di
comando
stiamo parlando di persone che producono
cultura e questa cultura è inquinata
perché l'albo di supereroi che state
leggendo
potremmo averlo scritto e disegnato
colorato o letterato noi il fumetto
educativo per vostro figlio le vostre
graphic novel l'albo che avete appena
comprato in edicola la striscia online
che vi ha fatto tanto ridere potremmo
averla scritta noi oppure
potrebbero averla scritta loro
e che tipo di messaggio di idee
propagherà un fumetto disegnato da una
persona che non si pone il problema del
rispetto
e il 2014
la marvel chiese a un artista italiano
di produrre la prima martina dell'albo
dedicata a spider woman quell'artista e
milo manara in italia a famosissimo per
il suo fumetto erotico ed immaginifico
ma cosa succede se togliamo l'artista
dal campo dell'erotico e lo mettiamo in
copertina di un albo che ha un pubblico
differente molto più eterogeneo
sessuali siamo oltre ogni limite la
donna in copertina mandiamo un messaggio
che non ha nulla più a che fare con la
potenza di un supereroe ma tanto a che
fare con la giustificazione sessuale
l'evoluzione della rappresentazione
delle donne o di qualsiasi minoranza nel
mondo del fumetto è un percorso molto
lungo faticoso e lentissimo
non dimentichiamoci che una delle eroine
più famose di questo mondo è susan storm
la donna invisibile
dei fantastici quattro
devo commentare il suo potere è
letteralmente scomparire
la copertina di manara alzato un bel po
vero polverone e ne natura discussione
vivace e anche feroce che dimostra come
i tempi stiano cambiando come non passa
più inosservato uno scivolone di questo
genere
la responsabilità di questa copertina
sbagliata non è di manara o del
direttore di collana o dell'art director
o del pubblico sensibile è tutto insieme
il meccanismo che ha fatto sì che
nessuno si ponesse la domanda ma
non sarà che questo culo voluttuoso ha
poco a che fare con la nostra
protagonista a cosa serve cosa racconta
siamo sicuri sicuri che vende di più
questo culo che un supereroe di spessore
ecco perché è così importante che la
comunità dei fumetti e soprattutto in
modo più esteso a tutti i produttori di
cultura diventino consci dei propri
stereotipi
che salva che sia alfabeti zino alla
diversità
e che aprano le porte al cambiamento
perché creano l'immaginario il nostro
immaginario i fumetti sono una cartina
tornasole per la cultura pop stessa non
esistono nel vuoto sono immersi nei
pensieri nei sentimenti e nei valori dei
loro scrittori e dei loro lettori
i fumetti agiscono come un agente di
socializzazione modellano i valori e gli
stereotipi sociali perché partono dall
immaginario e lo ripropongono ed è per
questo che è così importante che i
fumetti continuano a cambiare a proporre
alternative a raccontare quanto e
sfaccettata la realtà
ok abbiamo capito
abbiamo capito perché farlo ma come come
cambiare tutto come si fa la rivoluzione
si sgobba signori si vuole cambiare
qualcosa ci si applica si fatica e si
diventa alleati e cominciamo con il
prendere coscienza di tre cose
fondamentali
il potere è il primo grande elemento che
apre le porte all'abuso
se ci pensiamo
non abbiamo la descrizione precisa del
potere quando noi parliamo dobbiamo
parlarlo in una situazione non contesto
è facile identificarlo all'interno delle
gerarchie ma non così tanto se dobbiamo
parlare in astratto il potere non è un
valore oggettivo né una qualità o una
caratteristica intrinseca una persona
non posso dire io sono riccia
simpaticissima e potente vero nome falso
io sono riccio e inopinabile ma
simpaticissima e potente dipende
perché è il potere o la simpatia non lo
tengo da sola
solo in relazione a qualcun altro
e queste relazioni avrà un tempo un
luogo un contesto e dei partecipanti
precisi così a seconda di queste
varianti posso avere un avere potere
addirittura posso primavere potere e poi
diventare debole
intendiamoci il potere non è di per sé
qualcosa di buono e cattivo perché è il
fine per cui è usato a essere
determinante per citare un amico
il problema si pone quando il potere non
è più visto come responsabilità ma a
dino usato per fini coercitivi perché il
potere porta con sé due elementi
fondanti l'abuso e la molestia
il primo è che il potere
dall'opportunità crea il contesto adatto
ma soprattutto influisce sul
comportamento dell'altro che non potrà
non saprò o non vorrà a difendersi per
tutta una serie di ragioni
perdere il lavoro l'incolumità fisica
illuminazione pubblica
seconda ragione il potere porta un basso
rischio di punizione è innegabile che
chi abusa del potere lo fa soprattutto
perché sa che non ne subirà le
conseguenze
ed è proprio la natura mobile e
rischiosa del potere che ci impone di
essere coscienti del nostro di quando lo
abbiamo di quando non lo abbiamo e di
come usarlo una delle armi principali
per sapere in che punto siamo della
scala del potere e cosa ne stiamo
facendo è utilizzare il consenso ovvero
coinvolgere l'altro nel percorso
decisionale
dobbiamo imparare a chiedere il consenso
quando chiederlo e soprattutto gente
come negarlo qualche esempio
se dice no non ha il consenso se dorme
non ha il consenso se è svenuto svenuta
no non ha il consenso se dice forse non
lo so no non ha il consenso se dice sì
dopo che hai passato ore a tentare di
convincerla a convincerlo non hai
senso e coercizione si dice si ha il
consenso è esattamente così facile
facilissimo
alleniamoci a dire posso dire sì a dire
no
il secondo passo per diventare alleati è
capire che non esiste a un'escalation ma
un sistema interconnesso
nella nostra vita per orientarci siamo
abituati ad avere un sistema
quantitativo lineare cosa significa che
dopo uno ce 2 che 5 e meno di 7 che è un
tumore al quarto stadio terminale è il
primo a possibilità di guarigione
contiamo e diamo valore alle cose
ragionando su crescita e decrescita
abbiamo espressioni come la punta
dell'iceberg la piramide dei valori
per questo abbiamo un'idea piuttosto
lineare delle cose e della vita
uno degli esempi migliori è l'escalation
si parte dal basso un al poco grave si
arriva al gravissimo
il punto è che ci dimentichiamo che
questo modello lineare è uno stratagemma
sviluppato per orientarsi ma non
funziona nel mondo delle idee e della
cultura che non è un'escalation ma è un
sistema interconnesso
interconnessione significa che ogni
singola parte è collegata
se faccio le cup colin per strada sono
trento il sistema stesso che permetterà
un femminicidio se stesso rizzo un
collega al lavoro sono trento all'idea
stessa della busa le mie chiacchiere da
spogliatoio stanno costruendo l'idea
stessa della molestia rendono poco grave
la mancanza di rispetto l'oggettistica
zione la derisione tutti elementi che
non per no ignoranza e violenza
è ora di iniziare a usare il nostro
potere per farlo in modo responsabile
dobbiamo conoscere le conseguenze
e la conseguenza è
che stiamo ottenendo l'idea sbagliata
perché questo ci porta al terzo punto
siamo tutti tutti parte del problema che
ci riguarda in prima persona o no non
siamo fuori dal sistema
ne facciamo parte lo nutriamo e
perpetriamo le sue dinamiche
non esiste l'astensione se non prendiamo
posizione siamo automaticamente parte
del problema come rendersene conto c'è
un esercizio semplicissimo bisogna
iniziare etichettando se stessi facciamo
un esempio se io dico eterni a cosa
viene in mente come prima cosa asiatici
africani e mediorientali
come mai hanno un bianco non viene mai
in mente la sua etnia di appartenenza io
sono caucasica così voi lo stesso se uso
la definizione identità di genere gay
lesbo trans ma eterosessuale no e tra
sessuale
è come se avessimo una grande capacità
di categorizzare tutti gli altri ma non
noi stessi
no perché abbiamo inventato noi questo
gioco e adesso non possiamo non giocarlo
dall'alto del nostro privilegio perché
avere un privilegio è come ricevere
un'eredità
non ce la meritiamo non ce la siamo
guadagnati siamo semplicemente più
ricchi degli altri perché le regole e
sull'eredità
sono fatte dal nostro avvocato
non sono giuste non sono dei diritti ma
soprattutto non ci rendono c'è chi se
sei nato con un'eredità poi comunque
capire cos'è la miseria
il merito o la giustizia ed è questo il
punto chiave sapere che siamo ci fa
vedere in modo onesto il potere il
privilegio il contesto le persone che
abbiamo vicino e se prendiamo coscienza
di cosa significa responsabilità non
solo saremo persone
produrremo sogni migliori visioni
migliori racconti migliori e anche i
disegni migliori grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]